dernière-née de l'industrie automobile
française
la 404 peugeot a eu les honneurs de la
presse
complétant la gamme des 403 elle est
dotée d'un moteur inclinée à 45 degrés
d'une puissance de 900 chevaux fiscaux
développement 72 chevaux
côté confort les sièges inclinables
semble devoir satisfaire les plus
délicats
avec cela un coffre d'un demi mètre cube
10 litres aux 100 km et plus de 140 à
l'heure
non
le salon de l'automobile a fermé ses
portes mais ils nous offrent encore des
révélations
tel cet engin que nous verrons sans
doute en grand nombre dans les rues de
paris
comme on en voit déjà dans les cités
allemande cet engin dont on peut
constater tout de suite grâce à son
faible rayon de braquage qu'il a été
conçu pour la circulation dans les
villes encombrées s'appelle pelé et il
est construit par la firme allemande née
car ces trois roues et son faible
encombrement lui permettre de se garer
facilement mais surtout sa conception
il est animé par le moteur fiat 500 cm
cud deux cylindres opposés un plat
totalement effacé fait que pour un poids
de 500 kg il peut transporter 700 kg de
charge utile
plus le conducteur
si le peuple est conçu pour la
circulation en ville la renault 4l saint
parres est conçu pour l'utilisation
rural grâce à ses 4 roues motrices
la 4l sympa peu d'escaladé sans élan
dépendent de 45° que l'on peut qualifier
de prendre total et que l'on rencontre
rarement tout de même la 4l sympa et
classique
il y est simplement ajouter une boîte de
renvoi sur les roues arrière un crabe
otages permet sur route de n'utiliser
que les roues avant
depuis quelques jours au très peu
puisque sa présentation officielle
remonte à jeudi dernier
vous pouvez rencontrer cette voiture sur
nos sept voitures c'est la caravelle
l'un des deux nouveaux modèles de
printemps de renault déjà présenté
l'autre étant la floride s et qui
marquent l'évolution de la régie nation
car sous son apparence générale comme ça
vu de loin à peine différente de celle
de la floride 1956 la caravelle recèle
toute une série de modifications
techniques qui en font en fait une
voiture mais cette voiture nouvelle elle
se caractérise tout d'abord
extérieurement par un prolongement du
pavillon qui permet d'en faire un coupé
4 places
cette caractéristique est la seule qui
la différencie de la floride est-ce que
vous découvrez en ce moment en bas de
cette trempe et qui elle a gardé
l'apparence exacte du cabriolet floride
avec possibilité d'adjonction barre
mais pour les deux modèles la même
mécanique
cette mécanique elle très modifiée par
rapport à celle de la floride
tout d'abord sur le capot arrière vous
remarquez défends tu sais que le
radiateur est maintenant placé derrière
le moteur ce qui dégage de la place
devant et supprime les ouïes latérales
comme sur la r4 le plein du mélange de
refroidissement effet une fois pour
toutes
mais heureusement ce moteur qui est
maintenant 1 956 centimètres cubes à
cinq paliers à la course l alésage
modifié et qui développe 51 choix 5500
tour contre 40 chevaux à 5000 tours pour
l'ancien floride nouveau dessin des
tubulures et commandes de l'arbre à
cames par chaînes sont parmi les
éléments qui concourent à augmenter la
puissance de la voiture de 20%
l'emmenant à 135 km heure nouvel
embrayage suspension avant et arrière
modifiés direction plus directe grâce à
une modification de la géométrie de la
timonerie mais surtout freins à disques
sur les quatre roues concourt à faire de
la caravelle et de la floride des
voitures totalement nouvelle à signaler
également que les freins à disques
adopté ne sont pas assistés et présente
un certain nombre de solutions
originales avec leurs chevaux
supplémentaires en bas et en haut un
freinage amélioré permettant d'utiliser
ses choix au maximum les nouvelles
petites renault prennent donc place
parmi les voitures bien séduisante dalle
d'ailleurs vous allez pouvoir en juger
par vous même
puisque nous vous invitons à monter avec
nous dans une floride s
quand même on n'est pas galant on aurait
pu mettre votre femme votre place devant
entrer d'évident pour faire je crois
quand même là marseillais vivent
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'avoir
fait la floride est du résultat
il m'a de khattab waters désagréable la
première en amont du cac 40 la deuxième
fois soixante dix la troisième mois voir
ça obernai denni oui ailleurs la
quatrième le maximum 65
et puis elle est confortable elle était
confortable alors ne sais pas si c est
si sont les jambes de force qu'on
parlait le fichier tout à l'heure mais
l'impression qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup mieux faire président oui et se
tient très bien la route durant sociale
dira je n'avais qu'à signer deux années
voire bien dans le virage
à
retiens beaucoup mieux que l'ancienne
floride lors ce qui était intéressant
pour l'automobile us et d'avoir
également un freinage très puissant je
me dis ah oui j'avais dit qu'on va
essayer les points oui c'est un très bel
objet de la guerre aura la route n'est
bien on va y aller parce qu'on fait
quand vous allez voir
dans quelques jours une nouvelle voiture
circulera sur nos routes comme elle
circule depuis deux mois sur les routes
d'espagne
cette voiture c'est la r8 destiné à
compléter la gamme de production de la
régie renault et qui se présente comme
une voiture de catégorie supérieure à
ceux de la dauphine tout en étant comme
elle une cinq chevaux fiscaux
d'aspect extérieur la r8 à une ligne qui
lui permet tout en offrant à peu près la
même surface au sol que la dauphine
d'être plus vaste intérieurement on
remarquera les volets d'aération à
l'arrière du capot moteur identique à
ceux de la floride s ou de la caravelle
les organes mécaniques de la r8 sont en
effet les mêmes un moteur de 956
centimètres cubes à cinq paliers
développement 48 chevaux mais dont les
réglages sont davantage orientés vers la
souplesse que la performance en pointe
on retrouve encore sur la r8 le
refroidissement à circuit c'est les
légendes de force à l'arrière les freins
à disques sur les quatre roues la ligne
compacte de la voiture a permis
également d'agrandir le coffre à bagages
derrière lequel ce groupe devant le
tablier
l'appareil de chauffage et de
ventilation en ce qui concerne les
détails d'aménagement des serrures à
manoeuvre par bouton poussoir un tableau
de bord complet et qui comporte un volet
d'aération orientable à chaque extrémité
un vaste vide poches et des coussins
formé en mousse de polyester enfin
toujours pour le confort une vaste plage
devant la glace de custode
livrables souhaite avec une boîte à
trois rapports ou à quatre rapports tout
synchroniser la r8 à une vitesse
maximale de 125 kilomètres à l'heure
elle existera dans une gamme de huit
coloris
et si d'ailleurs vous désirez juger de
ses coloris vous le pouvez dès
maintenant car la r8 est déjà entrée en
production et cet après midi 60 d'entre
elles qui telle usine de flins et prenez
la direction de paris ce sont les
voitures qui feront partie de la
caravane du tour de france cycliste bien
sûr et qui en attendant le départ seront
garés porte de versailles
amara
nouveauté pour le prochain salon de
l'auto notamment sur les modèles 66
présenté par simca freins à disques sur
les roues avant de la 13 e st banquette
arrière rabattable sur la ville offrant
un important espace supplémentaire mais
c'est surtout la suppression de la
[ __ ] d'embrayage qui constitue
l'événement deux positions courante
routes ou villes montagne sur l'ami la
transmission semi-automatique une seule
position de marche sur la case sein à
boîte entièrement automatique un
sélecteur permet de choisir marche avant
point mort marche arrière par qui
l'automatisme qui permet sur route les
performances habituelles sera sans aucun
doute apprécié dans la circulation
urbaine où l'on calcule que trois heures
de conduite correspondent à 15 cents
débrayage soit à la dépense d'énergie
que représente l'ascension à pied de la
tour eiffel